brought to you by t-mobile
now Netflix has included another reason
why t-mobile is America's best unlimited
network before Star Trek discovery
forces you to boldly subscribe where no
one has subscribed before celebrate the
30th anniversary of the Star Trek
spin-off that gave rise to the ultimate
nerd question Kirk or Picard engage Star
Trek The Next Generation your dad loved
the original Star Trek's mix of campy
aliens cheesy dialogue and Razzie
caliber acting now get ready for the
original series geeky younger brother
featuring new aliens more complex
stories and acting that's way better
than Star Trek deserves in this kinder
gentler sequel where crew members
discuss their feelings celebrate each
other's cultures and fight with their
words not their fists I hereby formally
request third-party arbitration of our
dispute you have the right firm or
pursuant to subsection oh man being
civilized is boring warp into the 24th
century with an all-new USS Enterprise
an awkward hybrid of cutting-edge Space
Battleship and a Marriott Convention
Center members of the archeology council
I want to tell you about my detective
story and me an all new crew counselor
troi an empath who can always tell when
someone's lying except when she can't
what do you think it's hard to tell
I sense nothing what is it I don't know
something Geordi LaForge a blind
engineer who's here to say tech words a
cosmic string emanates a characteristic
set a subspace frequencies as atomic
particles decay along incident horizon
Worf a warrior who never runs out of
Klingon fun facts Klingons do not laugh
Klingons do not surrender Klingons do
not procrastinate Klingons do not allow
themselves to be probed Lieutenant
Commander data an Android who drops
being an Android into conversations like
your friend who just became a vegan why
do you have yellow eyes I am an Android
you're not human I'm an Android you some
like you don't want to be an Android I
am an Android I'm Will Riker the
horniest first officer in the fleet
who's never met a woman hologram
co-worker amnesia stricken crew member
or genderless androgynous alien he
didn't want a bone commander tell me
about your sexual organs dr. crusher
who's just kind of there most of the
time her son Wesley whose genius has
matched only by his skill at irritating
people I know this may finish me as an
acting ensign shut up Wesley I don't
think this is my style shut up kid may I
point out that shut up Wesley everybody
needs somebody enough and Captain
jean-luc Picard make it so the most
British Frenchmen in the galaxy tío Grey
hot excellent team
today watch world-class actor Patrick
Stewart remained fully committed to his
dialogue even when the writers clearly
fell asleep on their keyboards July's
nation teach cat jugni judge the job
rude its job the vacuum guitar schema
rough stuff
you remember the Romulans Klingons
and Vulcans from the original series now
get ready for all new species with all
new ways to glue prosthetics to people's
faces like the best Star Trek villains
ever the Borg resistances the Ferengi
literal but heads in serious need of a
dental plan cue and omnipotent trickster
with a serious man crush on Captain
Picard morning darling and the
Cardassians omnipresent leather skin
tyrants bent on Galactica domination I'm
sorry what's that oh sorry
and the Cardassian omnipresent leather
skin tyrants been done galactic
domination not sure which one I prefer
journey to a sci-fi utopia where poverty
racism and war are things of the past
and forget the original Star Trek's
miniskirt boys club she does a good job
all right it's just tonight I'm used to
having a woman on the bridge because on
this enterprise
the future is whoa Klingons appreciate
strong women
we no longer enslave animals for food
purposes I have decided to allow my
child to choose its own sex and
appearance at least most of the time
okay well at least things are better
right I mean the ladies aren't aw
stereotypical anymore I never met a
chocolate I didn't
damn it Troy so relive one of the
greatest pieces of science fiction ever
created
full of unforgettable moments and a few
that they wish you would forget like the
time the gang met Mark Twain shame on
you mr. Clemens shame the one where
Captain Picard turns into a kid I need
to see him now and the episode where dr.
crusher inherits a land that contains a
Space Ghost dinner late that kondal why
not it'll bring the ghost who sheep orcs
until it reanimates her grandmother's
corpse and attacks her friends it's all
right Nana's dead uh are we sure this is
as good as we remember storage original
series cameos data interrupted and what
Klingons do to their children they die
I'm not talking about parenting he
betrayed the colonists and would have
betrayed the enterprise as well had I
not the unhatched eggs of a large-scale
display that data death fake outz
Jordi's dead we're dead Geordi we are
not dead you're dead
[Music]
you killed him doppelgangers the card
mean faces that one lightening effect
[Music]
palm punches
acting no you've just committed an act
of utter barbarity
[Music]
anyway I'm not much of an actor
the Picard maneuver the Ryker maneuver
dr. Pulaski's being shown to her
quarters
you may want to start something like
this if you don't look like a person who
came here to relax something's wrong
tell sir Troy's ill okay Mordor concerts
lots and lots of concerts seriously
so many concerts and Worf getting his
ass kicked
[Music]
Star Trek the new class but seriously go
back and watch the episode where dr.
crusher bones a Space Ghost it's just
it's it's amazing
[Music]
we match now brought to you by t-mobile
now family plans include Netflix at no
extra charge another reason why t-mobile
is America's best unlimited network
carry on my wayward son there'll be
peace when you are done
I am Locutus aboard resistance is futile
hell warp nigh
engage